wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
auf gar keinen fall aber wieso dadurch
ist das risiko für euch nicht so hoch
habe ich weiß nicht ob uns richtig
verstanden hast aber es gibt kein risiko
mehr weil ist nämlich kein deal maker
ich weiß auch nicht ob das eine gute
idee ist der will für sein geld 50
prozent von unserem geschäft hand ist
viel zu viel das war doch klar dass das
nicht einfach so viel geld gibt nein das
war nicht klar
und ich hätte nicht gedacht dass er
neuer geschäftspartner werden will und
50 prozent vorne wie bekommt da ganz
sicher nicht denn wir brauchen ihn nicht
ich arbeite jedenfalls nicht umsonst das
soll so war die ganze sache sowieso viel
zu riskant tarek was denn
mich wundert ist unser restaurant größer
machen würde
so unzufrieden nein manche das ist der
plan
aber es tut mir leid pete hat recht das
ist unser restaurant wir wollen kein
investor
[Musik]